my name is emeka patrick jokoka i'm
presenting this um presentation
for this research fellowship program
analysis of transcriptomics profile
of a task of two infected cell lines
to understand the mechanism of action of
reproposed
drugs for covid19 treatment i did this
project
with the anita gangsta chronovirus
disease
as we all know has infected over 50
million persons
and over recorded over a million deaths
currently only remedies there have been
approved for the treatment of this
disease
with mixed results a few drugs were
computationally repurposed for the
treatment of this infection
however the mechanism of action of some
of these drugs
are still poorly understood regulated
need is an
anti-inflammatory drug that was proposed
for the treatment of severe cases
and has some clearly defined mechanism
of action
however amlodipine a calcium channel
blocker
is one of the few repurposed drugs for
kobe 19 and has shown to reduce viral
load
and has some yet to be clearly defined
mechanism
using publicly available data sets
or gene response from cell lines treated
with the virus
obsolete and ambrodipine we conducted
the differential gene expression and
pathway enrichment analysis
to elucidates the genes and pathways
involved in the mechanism of
action of amlodipine as we all know
regulatory is an established
non-selective inhibitor of the juxta
signaling pathway
here we showed that amlodipine has
significant jack starts signaling
pathway inhibition
and modulates other immune related
signaling factories
also we observed that the pathway in
which a number of genes were
significantly upregulated
were involved in innate defense
mechanism against these pathogens
we also discovered that amlodipine has
some
inhibitory effect on viral host
interaction that may benefit
as a potential antiviral and
anti-inflammatory drug
as shown ex02 we have three grades of
covid19
infection the asymptomatic the
non-severe
and the severe grid about 80 percent of
individuals actually have the
asymptomatic and non-severe grades
where 20 percent have the severe grade
different molecules cells and tissues
are involved at different stages or
different grades of this infection
as we'll see later on and this may
explain why different drugs are useful
at different
grades and different stages disease
the process is involved in immunity cell
division
cellular date and tumor formation
the pathway actually communicates
information from chemical signals
outside the cell
to the nucleus and results in activation
of
some genes there are three parts to the
start signaling part three we have the
janus kinase
the signal transducer and activator of
transcription protein
and the receptors to which the chemical
signals like the growth factor or the
cytokines
bind to we have three major proteins
that negatively regulates this signaling
pathway
and they are the suppressors of cytokine
signaling
the protein was of activated stat
and a protein tyrosine phosphatase
destruction in these signaling parts
actually leads to a variety of diseases
such as immune system
cancers and the skin conditions
we wanted to compare gene expression
profile from cell lines replicates
following their treatment with either
sas of 2 or subscribe 2
and the drugs to gain insight into genes
and signaling pathways involved in
blocking of two replication
and potentially reducing the viral load
equally to gain insight into the genes
and signaling pathways involved
in modulation of the hosts response to
the infection
and to gain insight into the mechanism
of action of amlodipine
for covin19 treatment
so the data sets as said earlier with
cell lines
they transformed lung i avula
transduce with the vector expressing
hormone h2
and they were treated with do a mock
treated or treated with sask of two
or for treated results of two and the
drugs
sequencing was actually performed using
the nexic 500
instruments illumina platform and
anywhere single end library layouts
and gene expressions were obtained
actually in
rsm calls
so this is our comparisons
our analysis plan was actually to
combine these data sets
normalize and filter them run a pca
then differential gene expression
analysis
we actually had two data cells that were
obtained from two different projects
the first data sets were gene expression
in raw data scores from triplicates
of the cell line that were treated with
either subscribe to and the drug and
those that were mock treated and this
contained
about 21 797 genes
the second data sets were gene
expression in raw data scores too
that were treated with sus2 and
amlodipine
and actually had 23 712 genes
this data says were meshed claimed that
duplicates were removed
using our studio packages so our
analysis results revealed
after normalization and augmented
transformation of the data set
the principle component and analysis
that was done revealed
that pca1 and vca2 accounted for
most of the variations subsequently
differential gene expression
and gene ontology part analysis were
conducted on the server tibel platform
for the sask of two and the mark three
test cell line comparisons
and two part ways that the virus
significantly upregulated the number of
genes
and the ten top part two is that
significant number of genes were
downregulated were highlighted
differential gene expression analysis
and machine ontology analysis
on the comparison between the source of
two and the task of two
and the resolutely revealed four
signaling pathways
that are going to name her significant
number of down regulated genes
as the last comparison revealed
several signaling pathway that has
significantly downregulated gene in the
presence of amyloid pain and
we highlighted the 10 top signaling
pathway that we
had a significant number of upregulated
genes
rig one like jack start and the antigen
processing and presenting signal impact
to be
are highlighted in this presentation
for purpose of discussion the suppressor
of cytokine signaling genes
a set of seven genes common to all the
three comparison
was shown in bad plots
this is the pchs of the samples that
were selected
and as we can see the variations across
these genes
across these samples are highlighted as
such
now this slide actually shows the
volcano plot of the comparisons between
the task of two and more created cell
lines
and highlighted our pathways of em
interest the juxta signaling pathway
and the regular like receptor signaling
pathway
with a significant difference in both
these cell lines that were treated with
this drug
with this same virus and the mock
treated them
still life highlighted here or the
fourth significantly
different part in which the number of
genes were downregulated due to roxality
highlighted in turquoise blue the our
pathways of
interest here too likewise
this is a findings in the comparison
between the
saskhof2 and the south
amlodipine treated cell lines here is
the comparison between the
pathways signaling the rig one like
receptor signaling pathway
it reveals significant upregulation of
genes involved in reward like signaling
part three
that are involved in pro-inflammatory
response
with type one interferon and some
inflammatory cytokines we can see the
comparison between the cells versus more
comparison
and the size vessels starts and i'm
loading comparisons
in this pathway second number of genes
involved in negative regulation of this
signaling pathway the soc genes the tcpt
genes
and those preventing apoptosis we
actually
upregulated by cells whereas in the
presence of amlodipine they were
downright related
and we can see that on the roxylantinep
pathway comparison some of the
the down regulation we're not as
significant as that in the
amlodipine comparisons
the suppressor of cytokine signaling
genes
is a set of seven genes and here we
highlighted the
comparisons between the cells and the
more treated cell lines
and the stars and this also analogy
being treated cell lines
this is a bad plot highlighting the
changes that were observed
and the significant values another
signaling factor
that we had some sometime regulated
genes or an upregulated genes
where it was the antigen processing
and presentation signaling pathway here
we will
observe opposite changes in the cells
vessels
cells and have blood being comparison as
compared to the cells vessels
as an obsolete technique comparison
significant genes were upregulated where
the
killer inhibitor receptor genes and the
mhc
genes in class one and two genes
here several host signaling pathways are
hijacked by sask of two virus to ensure
its survivor
and replication this project showed that
some of the genes involved in the juxta
signaling pathway
and the reward signaling pathways are
significantly upregulated by this virus
it also shows that virals may also down
regulate genes associated with key
innate
cellular defense mechanism amlodipine
appears to reverse some of the key
changes
and may explain why these drugs is
effective in reducing viral load
and improve states of patients with
severe disease infected with this
virus the drug start and the reward
signaling pathway
are necessary in several cellular
functions
take regular signaling pathway which is
involved in type 1 interferon response
is necessary to limit the virus from
spreading to nearby cells
and promote an innate immune response
including
inflammatory response and helps in the
activation of the adaptive
immune system rig one is essential
in innate immune system for recognizing
cells that has been infected with the
virus infections with task of two virus
results in downstream release of type
one interferon
and pro-inflammatory cytokines an
over-expression of these changes may be
responsible for cytokines storms seen in
severe cases
associated with this infection as seen
in existing findings in literature
log solution eventually down regulates
genes involved in the rig one signaling
pathway
as seen in this project and may explain
its mechanism of action in its use for
severe cases
the virus in addition to of regulating
the jack and start genes
particularly of regulations that are
involved in
negative regulations of this signaling
factory
so pressures of cytokine signaling
protein inhibitors of activated start
and protein tyrosine
phosphatase are negative regulators of
jack start
signaling pathway and we're shown to be
significantly upregulated
in this project other downstream genes
that were significantly upregulated
included the mcl1 pim1 and
cmxc mcn1 directly inhibits apoptosis
and cmic is an important regulator gene
and sometimes
acts as a transcription factor involved
in cell cycle propagation
cell proliferation and differentiation
the indirect implication of this is that
the virus prevents apoptosis
of the infected cell lines and limits
the host's innate
immune activation of the host innate
immune mechanism of defense
and thereby ensuring its unabated
replication
and survival in this project it was
observed that in the presence of
amlodipine the socs
pias and ptp were significantly direct
related
likewise the cmic mcl1 and pim genes
were significantly downregulated this
effect may restore the natural functions
of jack start signaling pathway
in the presence of cough ii i may
explain some of the mechanism of
action of amnodipine inhibiting viral
replication
and survival compared with
the effect of proximity those similar
patterns are well observed
however a number of these genes remained
unchanged
that's with regards to representing the
pia1
s and the pim1 chains
resolution needs effects as seen in this
project
acts more on the rig one signaling
pathway
which may explain its usefulness in the
treatment of cytokinestop
associated with infection in keeping
with findings in some studies
lastly the effects seen on antigen
processing and presentation due to
amlodipine is almost opposite
that senior auxiliarity name which looks
like
this project was observed that is the
unicorn number of genes who were
downregulated in the process involving
the antigen
processing and presentation a group of
genes known as a killer cell in
immunoglobulin-like receptor genes where
downregulated significantly by russian
kidney
while being upregulated significantly by
amlodipine
the kiru genes are involved in the
regulation of the killing function of
natural ocular cells
they do this by modulating how these
cells interact with the major
histocompatibility
cell class 1 molecules expressed
on all nucleated cell types mhc class 1
and mhc
class 2 genes were also significantly
upregulated by
amlodipine it's important to know that
most kiro genes are inhibitory
meaning that the recognition of mhc
molecules
suppresses the site to toxicity
activities of
nk cells though a limited not few
of these genes are stimulatory in nature
the precise nature of these effects due
to amplitude need to be studied
for that it appears generally
amlodipine enhances the detection of
virally infected
cells by both init and adaptive immune
systems
the precise effect of these needs to be
further clarified
in conclusion we found that task of 2
infection hijacks the jack start and
regular signaling pathway
by upregulating some genes genes
upregulated by subscribe to
inject star signaling pathways i involve
negative regulation of this pathway
although depends significantly directly
genes involved in the negative
regulation of the juxta signaling
pathway
an amlodipine may be involved in the
modulation of immune response
to viral infection due to saskof2
by upregulating genes involved in
antigen processing
and presentation some of the limitations
observed here was the sample size
and the cell lines which are not typical
representations of living hosts
this is the link to the raw data and the
reference publications that were used
thank you for listening